Stargate Announcement by December
12th why welcome to SRE your SciFi TV
and Movie
[Music]
Channel so slythering the game
developers have been talking about
timekeepers the new Stargate game today
they have been celebrating also the 29th
anniversary of the Stargate movie being
released and as part of the celebration
today they released a date for when the
game will be available they've also
released the first chapter of this game
there's going to be seven chapters
within the game they've released the
first chapter for a free download the
link will be in the description you can
go and play the first chapter of this
new game I would absolutely adore you
guys to then come back to this video and
leave a review and then Monday after
I've had a good go with the game I'm
going to review it and I would love to
add some of your reviews to do that so
get in
there and this December 12th date why do
I think that's important I've always
said and I've been told by a couple of
sources but it's a little bit
unconfirmed that the game was being
delayed purposefully because they wanted
to wait until the um Stargate whatever
it is they doing movie series whatever
we think a movie but was announced
because basically Stargate has been off
as screens for well over a decade was it
14 years now and at the end of the day
if Amazon and MGM announc the new
Stargate project and then they release
the game the game will get a lot more
traction it will sell a lot more so they
are trying to build up a bit of hype but
at the end of the day they really need
MGM and Amazon to actually make this
announcement and we're hearing loads of
rumors of that's coming really soon so I
actually think there's a a very good
possibility it could be within the next
week I'm keeping a very close eye on all
of the press
releases but by December 12th I am going
to say I am six chevron's locked on that
happening I am 90% confident if it
doesn't happen I will really really
wonder why and I will be amazed really
if I'm honest but guys what do you think
get into the comments this is a very
quick video from my kitchen because you
know I've just made my tea which hence
the the mess but um I really would love
you guys to tell me what you think about
this do you think I'm overthinking this
do you think the December 12th date is a
red herring do you think actually Amazon
care what Slytherin are doing with this
game or do you think like I do that
actually it is relevant and that is why
Slytherin had been delaying it so long
remembering this game was supposed to be
out like a year ago so guys get into the
comments tell me exactly what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification you know what to do also
you can go to
patreon.com where most of our videos
appear first and you can watch them
without the adverts of YouTube so you
know give it a go as always please stay
safe I'll see you next
[Music]
time